be sure to check out Rob plays there you
can hang out with me while we play video
games and talk about life stuff
in the world of comic books you got two
different types of readers you have your
casual readers and you have your
hardcore readers the casual readers are
the guys that go into a comic book store
once every few months you know they're
just kind of curious as to what
Superman's been up to and they buy a
Superman comic maybe they just go and
they buy trades you know maybe they're
only subscribed to one book they want to
read Jonathan Hickman's east of West you
know and and so that's that's all they
get it's all they really care about the
hardcore readers are the ones who have a
poll list every week they go to the
comic book store they always get the
same line of stories maybe it's two
stories maybe just three stories maybe
it's all of them from Marvel and DC and
valiant and image and so on but the fact
remains they're there diligently week in
and week out getting comics the common
theme among these two groups is that
they got into comics in a multitude of
different ways for people like me
I got an ax coming books in the 1990s
because I was watching x-men the
animated series and I loved x-men the
animated series and I still think to
this day it's the greatest comic book
show of all time Batman the Animated
Series is in a close second I know that
that will probably create some debate in
the comments and I'm curious which one
do you guys think is better post a
comment down below but that got me into
in the comics you know I was so enamored
by the x-men but it really wasn't the
x-men themselves because I saw what was
interesting in the TV show I was curious
about everything else I was curious
about Captain America that was curious
about Iron Man
I was curious about Thor the Avengers
you know the Fantastic Four I'd heard
these things and my dad would tell me
stories about when he read comics but he
was young he would tell me about how Hal
Jordans weakness was the color yellow
and I was always curious if you hit him
with a yellow crayon would that take
away his powers you know of course we
know that now that's not really the case
but you know as a kid it was always a
funny question to ask
some people got into college because of
Batman the Animated Series you know some
people grew up in that age and they said
wow that man is so cool I wonder what
his comics are like and they go to the
comic book store and they buy Batman the
Animated Series maybe they buy net they
buy nightfall you know I guess about in
the comic series rather they buy a knife
fall you know they see that Bruce
Wayne's back is broken by Bane he's
incapacitated jean-paul Valley takes
over the mantle for a while Dick Grayson
does it for a little bit longer and then
eventually Bruce Wayne comes back maybe
they watch Batman the Animated Series
and it was around the time when I guess
shortly after his Superman died and they
said what's going on with this the death
of Superman is a huge deal and they
bought another Superman and they
followed up after rate of the Superman
the introduced the introduction of the
metropolis kid Conner Kent of the
Eradicator of Hank Henshaw cyborg of
John Henry irons steel they bought into
this huge landscape of characters and
for some people it's recent Iron Man
came out 2006 2007 2008 somewhere on
there Kevin roughed up my head Iron Man
came out and they said Wow
Robert Downey jr. is an amazing Tony
Stark I wonder what he's like in the
comics they go to they kind of bookstore
and they see an event called Marvel
Comics Civil War a hundred issues long
they buy it in trade and they just rip
through the pages just just tearing
through one page right after the next
you got Tony Stark and Captain America
fighting each other you got you know
Captain America fighting spider-man
you've got this great big huge showdown
this you know Michael Bay explosions at
the end of the whole thing and they're
like this is so cool and because of that
they start getting into comics they're
like well what are the x-men doing well
the expert have been d powered so while
Civil War is going on you have
decimation after decimation you got
Messiah Complex and then you got Messiah
War and you got you know Second Coming
you got all these different things that
are going on you got anihilation going
out in space and they're just like wow I
didn't realize the comics were this huge
that there was so much going on in this
community and so before people know it
suddenly this this concept of pop
culture that was kept hidden that was
you don't talk about that in the public
you hang out with your friends at your
house in your basement and you talk
about comics suddenly it was everywhere
people were flocking by the millions to
go see the old comic book related
multimedia maybe it was just movies
maybe it's just TV shows maybe they
never actually buy a comic but it opens
them up to this much bigger world
everything that's right about comics in
my mind is underscored by DC Lee birth
and I know that there are a lot of
Marvel fans on my channel that will get
really irritated about that
I know there are hardcore fans and to me
that's not a bad thing I think one of
the greatest aspects of the color book
community is the conviction that comic
book fans have DC fans and Marvel fans
remain steadfast in their trenches and
they will not give ground
DC's better than Marvel Marvel's better
than DC that's just the way it is you
know and it creates some really
interesting discussion on who has the
best characters who has the best stories
who has the best universe so on and so
forth that debate aside the reason why
DC rebirth is so great is because it
blends the old and the new for fans who
grew up watching DC content grew up
watching Batman the Animated Series
Superman the animated series Justice
League Teen Titans Justice League
Unlimited for those people who grew up
watching these shows they resonated with
them maybe somebody got into comics from
Justice League and they really liked
Wally West like I really like the Wally
West character he's funny you know but
he's got it where it counts in the TV
show and the cartoon show they're like I
really want to get into him and so they
start reading mark Wade's run and the
more they get into it the more they
realized that that Wally West is a deep
character in the comics he's not just a
guy that runs fast that can outrun the
universe depending on what story you're
talking about he is a guy who got his
powers in the same way as Barry Allen he
was there before crisis on Infinite
Earths he fought alongside Barry Allen
his Kid Flash he lived through crisis on
Infinite Earths and he experienced Barry
Allen's death and in the post-crisis
landscape the duties of flash fell to
him the weight of the flash mantle fell
on his shoulders then it wasn't just
running really fast it wasn't just
fighting bad guys it was carrying the
legacy of Barry Allen everything that
Barry Allen stood for was now on the
shoulders of Wally West and you
in his stories you saw him going day by
day not wanting to disappoint the legacy
of Barry Allen you saw it day by day
trying to find his place in the
superhero community and he had his ups
and downs
he was poorer than he struck it rich he
was a character that was defined by his
experiences and the coming-of-age style
of storytelling from Mark Twain
resonated with readers because maybe the
young boy or the young girl that was
reading his comic understood what it was
like to have to deal with a legacy maybe
they had a really successful older
brother or older sister and they
understood the dichotomy they understood
that it's tough to live up to that
legacy with Mark Wade's writing but he
gave us things like the speedforce and
prior to that we didn't really know how
the speedsters powers worked all we knew
was that Barry Allen was splashed with
some chemicals it was assumed to have
moved his molecules at a really fast
rate or something along those lines and
because of that he was just able to run
super fast but with the Speed Force now
we had a uniting unifying factor not
only that we had a backstory to max
mercury the first speedster we had a way
to unite all these extremely fast
characters that operated under the
banner of the flash or some part of the
flash family in DC Comics this set the
stage for the future of the flash
franchise it set the stage for Geoff
Johns to come back in to say the Speed
Force didn't just exist it wasn't just
there one day Barry Allen was creating
it every time he ran he literally
generated this force of energy and
because of that he feeds everybody it's
the source of the speedsters power when
they die it's where they go it's their
afterlife it helped to create this huge
unifying world and for the hardcore
comic fan and for even maybe the casual
fan they loved it they loved that
character of Wally West because he was
there flash it Barry Allen was not there
flash max mercury was not there
speedster Wally West was there flash the
same is said about Batman Wonder Woman
Aquaman Green Lantern and so when DC
came along in new 52 and they wiped the
slate clean they said we're done
everybody everything's being rebooted
Batman's history may or may not be
intact it depends but Green Lantern
after Geoff Johns run that stays intact
which is kind of a good thing because
nobody was really reading Green Lantern
before that in fact
- the fans came on with Jeff Jones run
because it was so well done but fans
felt betrayed with the new 52 and the
reason why is because they felt like
they've spent so much time and so much
money they were part of the DC family
they were the foundation by which DC
built its success and then DC had come
along and said okay like we're done with
you now we're moving on to you people
they felt abandoned they felt just
shoved aside they felt betrayed you
could see that on social media you could
see it in forum posts you could see it
everywhere
you saw it in sales try as they might DC
simply didn't seem to find a way to keep
those fans satisfied not only that for
the casual come of accretor yes the new
number one sold very well because they
were like yes this is the jumping-off
point but in their mind for the casual
fan the Superman was not a guy who was
emo more or less Superman was the
experienced the wise standing up for
something greater he's seen some things
kind of guy that was a Superman they
knew the Superman that was a character
to aspire to and so for them the stories
just didn't resonate because it wasn't
the character that they had come to
expect
it wasn't the character that they had
come to believe existed right wrong or
otherwise it was not their character DC
Weber signifies everything right with
comics because it's a recognition that
yes hardcore fans will almost always be
there but like fans of anything else
they can become fed up they will walk
away if the product they're getting is
not the product they bargained for if
they were sold on a bill of goods and
that what they get is not what they pay
for they will walk away at the same time
if casual fans aren't interested in the
characters that they're getting they
won't read with DC rebirth we get a best
of both worlds we get the new 52
landscape that people have come to
expect we get the the forever evil
landscape we get the Darkseid war
landscape we get the Trinity war
landscape if that's your thing we keep
all that stuff all that history is still
there but then you get the wally west
that you know and love you get the
old-school superman not the new 52 you
get the superman that's iconic the
superman that you think of when you see
an image
on Google search that's the Superman
that you're getting he may not look the
exact same way but what he believes his
convictions how he views the world his
marriage to Lois Lane that is the
Superman that you get and that's the
Superman fans wanted not to mention
right now they've introduced mr. oz as a
villain not much is known but one of the
fan theories going around is that is
Ozymandias but for those of you guys who
never read Watchmen there were a lot of
similarities between the movies in the
comics the graphic novel but at the end
of the graphic novel
dr. Manhattan sided with Ozymandias he
agreed that yes as heinous as Ozymandias
Act was it is the logical course of
action to unite humanity is it a stretch
is it really a stretch to believe that
Ozymandias and dr. Manhattan are working
together behind the seams in the DC
rebirth landscape it certainly raises
some eyebrows and raises some questions
but in my mind everything right with
comics is signified by DC rebirth
because it is the landscape that we've
known the last five years but it's a
return to the familiar characters that
we've known for the last 25 years with
that being said guys we're gonna bring
this video to an end let me know if you
guys enjoy videos like this make sure
you guys drop a like if you did and make
sure you hit the sub button to become
part of the Rob core and yeah I will
catch you guys later peace
[Music]